let's join the tournament this late
joining
almost two hour long tournament probably
get in
maybe a couple games here oh am i gonna
play mr
kushage who also joined
it's possible i think we're both waiting
for a game
may the fourth month be with you i've
lost
three times for mr kusaj who's also a
streamer
who re-subbed yesterday um
have i been black every single game
i'm trying to remember what openings we
we've played before but now i forget
oh carol khan oh this is a good prep for
uh tomorrow cause lovey plays carol khan
i don't know yet what i'm gonna play
against levy
what do i play against carol khan
i'll play so my last match against levy
i played
this exchange variation loving all the
youtube content recently we're queen c7
knight a3
and we we went very deep into theory i
wonder how well
mr kushage is prepared i think h3 is a
move here
i should review this um
because otherwise if i develop the
knight there's bishop g4
so h3 is like a small nuance and black
either has to do this or this
uh appreciate people using their prime
subs thank you riddler
yeah so it's kind of a weird development
setup like knights on e2
and c2 uh now i'll play bishop
f4 hitting the queen
very possible we'll end up trading the
bishops
i don't have too much specific like
memory of preparation from this
this position but i know it gets very
strategic
usually the knight can come here i'm not
entirely sure if i want to trade off
b4 is a typical move
two months with many more to come
i could also i could start by taking but
in some way that actually strengthens
that structure
yes yeah actually c4 on move two has
been
one of my main weapons
oh thanks for that pog
yeah i used to play like pamela boffinik
and scientifically
all the content eric okay so we're
completing development thank you for the
bits
vegas subi
there's a similar idea um and the
queen's gambit declined exchange
variation
so it'd be reversed but when you push
the pause
two months watching your stream now
ooh happy two months louise priyante
and so many people cheering and subbing
really appreciate it
shanghai check asking if i'll be going
to national or us opens
okay i think a5 is a move to play still
in my comfort zone
um yeah because the queen has to go all
the way back and now
i feel like i have a very similar
position against levy
uh where it becomes very positional
knights want to be here and here
eventually on d3
i might start with knight t1
rookie one also flexible
black has the idea of maneuvering the
knight here
and also an idea of black eventually
playing e5
so i'll address comments and questions
a bit later i love you too whoever you
are
uh like scene 194 knight d3
e5 there's also knight c194 f3
knight d6 knight b3
huh it's also just rookie
one they'll start with rookie one
to address this okay i'm not addressing
it
even though when i say that i'm kind of
addressing it
fell into the trap of addressing it
what is e6 e6 is very solid
um
oh there's another weird idea which i
might do i might put the rook on c1
i shouldn't be taking time like these
moves are very low risk moves i should
have played much much quicker
um the idea with rook c1 is to free the
a1 square for the night
it's not about where the knight is it's
about where the knight is going
very soon it will be going to
the promised land on c5
c5 it's kind of like an artificial
outpost
because even though there's a pawn on on
b7 whenever the pawn moves up i take it
so that's a very nice square for the
night
it's common like in more closed
positions you
you want to sometimes be creative with
the night maneuvers identify the key
squares they want to get to and then
find the
the paths sometimes it's uh
takes a little bit of creativity oh i
love you too icelandic chess noob
i love your country too even though i
haven't been there in a while
okay somehow i'm up on time despite
being distracted
a little bit in the opening am i
managing
i like these positions thoroughly enjoy
your content
oh i thoroughly enjoy saying your name
rope-a-dope rope-a-dope
um yeah like usually my style especially
when streaming these days is like
gambits and aggressive play but
this game kind of it embodies my
over-the-board style
like solid positional play um
more kind of closed maneuvering game so
now i'm threatening to take and take
rook b8 would walk into a pin rook a7
looks sad
so now maybe queen g queen g3 runs into
knight h5
there's a funny line here here oh no my
queen
probably not worth it so this might want
to be here
or here
considering f3 just restricting 94 but
probably not necessary
more bits for the badge and reminder who
do you think was the most
creative player love you eric uh
maybe dubov or morphe i don't know
um i gotta focus after this game i'll
take some time
address the questions there's another
moment i should not be
taking too much time a rook c2
and rook c2 opens up possibilities i was
thinking king h1 knight g1 but it would
lead up f2 undefended
so rook on c2 potentially defends f2
prepares some maybe eventual double up
also opens the c1 square for this knight
i probably want to come to d3
um
not sure if i want to trade bishops
i play queen f3 first
but yeah i'm going for kind of the
squeeze i'm trying to find my optimal
setup
which is probably rookie 2 93 95
etc
actually maybe my queen should be on e3
to
enable f3 this is a one piece that's
kind of annoying in black's position
actually queen here knight c1 queens or
knight c4 queen c1
what does eric have a ba in that should
be on my wiki
my wikipedia page if that still exists
not sure though but i know what i have a
ba in but i'll discuss
so now if i take i win a pawn but then i
lose a pawn
that's probably not a good trade for me
um
[Music]
yeah knight b5 is very reasonable
uh if i play knight e5
95 things get weird
because f6
actually not sure i could play rook c1
solid move
yeah it's um the knights are tingling
and black actually found some nice
squares for the knights
you should keep in mind there's no
increment in this game so this could
come down to
some kind of time scramble
okay so this simplifies a little bit uh
so the black knight is finding its way
to c4
not too harmful put the rook back on e
file
so i'm doubled up on the only half woven
file um
right now i mean e6 is very well
supported but
there's a benefit of black never being
able to play f6
at least in the near future so i'm
basically threatening bishop
yeah i'm threatening bishop g5 because
here here
some pin rooks tie down to the pawn so
there's no rookie gate
i'm actually i'm controlling a lot of
squares in black's territory so the
pieces don't really have so much room to
maneuver
at b6 i probably just take it
i might actually win the oh never mind
now if i play this move so rook swings
over
i might actually
i want to swing over to the a file
because there's a target
it's the best way to do this
bishop g5
there's a funny line enjoying your chill
chess content
oh i enjoy your words
okay i'm gonna play bishop g5 because i
feel like it will make black think like
where to move the rook
yeah the funny line is after rookie i
play knight g7
um followed by knight f6
and basically what's i think what's
going to happen is
i get nine of six i either win the
exchange or
i get a monster bishop and then create
some mating ideas
and the queen's a bit out of play i mean
maybe we'll see queen d6 here
we trade queen of f8 but then i
i can kind of milk both sides of the
board
i feel like a farmer
yeah so this is kind of um it's a nice
example of the principle of two
weaknesses
where there's weaknesses on the king
side but there's also this weakness on
the queen side
[Music]
so i'm going to try and spread black
thin
like butter turn the milk into butter
not sure if this metaphor makes any
sense so if rook 8 i have b5
roxy it i take it ah there's 97
this move it gets weird
almost as weird as my metaphors let's
take it
so knight d7 knight's coming to e4
i did win upon i have a pass pawn just
have to watch
time
no you're not uh queen e3 or queen d3
probably doesn't matter too much
kind of like queen d3
because when i have the dorks for a
bishop i want my queen controlling light
squares
oh that's a fork
oh no ah my position okay i have to play
bishop b5
that's a fork uh let's play this move
i'm still alive but i forgot c3 was
hanging
i like the biggest weakness in the
position too
and my time and i'm throwing a sneaky
move queen a1 hitting the
rook which is defended but i'm also
having eventual ideas of back ranking
black
back ranking black
the black might back rank me too but
like queen c8 is actually
oh there's a funny line
or is there never mind
so now e6 is undefended
okay bishop's probably coming here oh
the bishop defends c1
i don't know if i would have like
considered bishop f4 against queen c8
oh queen c hits a rook so i guess
queensy i would have had to play rook a1
but now with queen c i play queen a1
okay position's getting weird i'm
attacking the pawn
just still undefended
i've i think i've i went wrong like
blundering the pawn earlier but now
it's still still looking nice
um queen h5 i mean maybe i just pushed
the b
pawn pass pawns must be pushed
okay so we're we're getting into some
time scramble
rook a8 king g7
like i wasn't sure whether to include
rook eights but
i like the rook uh focused on the pawn
because queen h5 i can
then take
okay that's a move
that's a reasonable move okay kg7
f3 almost traps a knight
but doesn't quite but maybe i play f3
anyway
oh there's knight g3
oh what is this position
let's start with start with this
to watch out for 92
okay i'm going to put the bishop on the
solid square
have this diagonal
queen a2
queen c7 or queen c2
restricting the knight threatening the
smell
okay now i'm threatening this and etc
mainly etc
wow
king h2 always good to have the king
diagonal one square from the knights or
two squares from the knights
oh tickle the knight the queen shade is
actually consideration soon
followed by this and this
oh let's trade let's trade
okay so it's still pressuring the book
and it's a weird position because i'm
not sure how to make progress
i might move here and then here
oh it might be a draw too but hopefully
not
yeah so there's perpetual threat so i'm
controlling e1 very important
so queen g3 here there's no queen e1
and now i put the rook behind the pawn
and now let's um let's put the king wait
is this
it's not quite neat
oh that was a blunder by me ah
i lost my baby pawn
no
now all my pieces
ah if if the king took the pawn it would
have been stalemate
oh that's such a fun game too
it came down to time good game mr
kushage
also shout out uh fellow streamer i
don't think he was streaming though
um if we analyze
that was such a nice game but i didn't
quite turn the
milk into butter
look at this graph too i was flying high
but not high enough man
what did i miss easy win
okay so h4
uh there's this plan queen 8 rook a7
yeah i guess i should have been aware of
like black it's hard to make progress on
the king's side there's no reason to
take
um i'm sure there are a lot of
opportunities here
and then yeah even here
around here this is time scrambling
okay that was a fun game i'll put that
on youtube
i'll leave a link to my uh opponent's
twitch channel
and if he has a youtube channel check
out the video description on youtube
and thanks for watching and
follow on twitch